hosti what's up everyone
Anna Mack here for anime uproar and
welcome to another episode of red cafe
episode 4 zero everyone and in this one
we're gonna be talking some fun talk
about my hero academia the best quirks
in my academia what type of quirks you
would want to have whether existing
quirks or perhaps a curve that you would
like to create if you had the choice
because I saw an are my hair anemia
videos a ton of people were talking
about this exact thing in the comments
talking about what kind of work would
you have what kind of work would you
create if you could create a quirk so I
thought it would be a fun little topic
to discuss with you guys in the chat
I'll have you in the chat kind of talk
about what quirks you would want to have
or create and then we just like
criticize what you said you know like
analyze it and then make you feel bad
and all that kind of stuff so yeah let's
do this I can't wait I can't wait to see
what recon comes up with the quirk to
become Kirito in real life I will create
myself an essay Oh quark I don't know
what I'll call it but it's gonna be
don't need to think about it though okay
okay okay yeah
before we get into it just to introduce
our own that's joining us today we have
of course anime recon we have brigs from
all the anime back again yeah we have
some Briggs we have all the anime dude
first time I ran cafe
what's up anime is it is I'm always
present to chat dose doesn't really feel
like it
yeah the anime dude is a big supporter
of rank efface so now we have them on
live live
we also NOx Taku back again aka Deku the
rapper what's up bro
nothing much thanks to me teams tennis
team 10 is staying liddie do you mean we
I mean we've ten of course yes we are
we've ten brought in the latest video
anime parody of Jake pulse it's everyday
bro called it Santa my bro is up on this
channel if you haven't seen it yet I was
a lot of fun we laughed our asses off
while making it not you did a great
Sinai blizzard was on there as well it
was really fun and we also have soul
maka joining us good old soul maka here
to pour cold water on the lar shown in
dreams what's up soul yeah but yeah and
this for this for this stream I
definitely want you guys in the chat to
be engaged come and tell me what your
what kind of quark you would want to
have whether in the world of my here
academia where everyone else has a quark
or even in the real world what could I
do you think would be useful in the real
world even if no one else had a quark
that kind of stuff I'd love to hear from
you um does anyone here on the panel
have an idea what kind of quark you
would want to have if you had a choice a
prepared idea I have a prepared idea if
you guys want to hear it so I know like
some of you guys are fans of the seven
deadly sins so my quark is gonna kind of
be based off like something similar to
Merlin's ability she possesses the
ability infinity so I'm not gonna have
magic powers like Merlin so I'm gonna be
like like support character in a sense
so like for example if Shoto
like freezes someone I could use the
power of infinity and like make that ice
infinite then basically what that does
is like that ice could never melt or if
you set someone on fire you'll burn
forever until you die you cannot put it
out even if you like dump water on it I
can't use those abilities myself my
ability is just to make things infinite
and I keep it make like my lifespan
infinite or like like my age eternal I
like the age that I am type of thing so
I think it's pretty dope you like I
could pick like the strongest hero all
might get them on my squad boom you're
immortal we could protect the world
forever yeah that's cool that's a good
idea and I also think you know if you
read the manga there does appear to be
quirks in my hero payment that allow you
to live longer or potentially forever so
that is interesting I think like we want
to stay obviously within the rules of
that world so we don't wanna go like my
quirk is to be able to do everything all
the time like that's that's too ope you
know the quirks have to have some limits
damn there goes my super saiyan Kitty
toe idea
we'll be racing I think mine was
realistic like as long as it's within
like 20 meters of me it's like boom
that's infinite well I was gonna say did
any I hope everyone here watched bungo
stray dogs yay no one I've heard good
things though I lost it well I really
liked how the powers were set up in a
bongo straight dog's universe in fact I
think I preferred bongo stray dogs to my
hero academia all in all but that'll
require a whole different rant there
were very original powers there like for
the most part what you see in bok'nor
here academia aside from a few
exceptions all might super strong and
you know Todoroki is Fire and Ice and
back to go could blow stuff up I mean
these are rather cliche quirks done
really well
whereas in bongos tree dogs they have
weirder abilities and limitations that
well if no one watched it there's no
point discussing well I think that you
know there are some you know classic
quirks in my email but there's also some
very strange quirks as well that have
strange limitations mostly for the more
side characters but definitely I think
that there are some interesting examples
you know all the top of my head we have
nimita obviously how I was just about to
mention him
you can't yeah yes a speck of quark
right um like but I mean useful
characters okay okay well she's fast
I've got something stains quark is quite
weird okay I mentioned in a video though
that stains quark is useless if he would
if he would poison his knives then he
would be way more dangerous than he is
with his quark I never actually thought
of that I thought watch your stains I do
but yeah man that is quite an
interesting thing yes I think if stain
would have had no powers at all you have
had no quark and he would have poisoned
his knives with something that paralyzed
he would have been way better villain
showing deku look what I am but okay the
majority of his strength comes from the
fact that he's like really a dryland
fast right like it's not even his quirk
as much night is Corky's useless the
only thing I'm thinking is maybe you
can't get your hands on poisons that's
that potent in that world so easily but
yeah that is definitely a good point
from the chat we had Kiwi fantasy say
he'd want to absorb knowledge and skills
from other people that would be great
that's very interesting
Rick because I know Merlin again from
something that since has a lust for
knowledge so that's going back to the
Briggs example before sledding for
knowledge
yeah t4c says deck was mom squirt
because I'm lazy and I think that's what
it should say quick like Becky's mom's
quirk is perfect if you're like on the
couch you don't want to get up and the
remote is on the other side of the room
but again telekinesis telekinesis is
something she you know it's seen
everywhere it's not an original quirk
all right I've got quirk it's not
related to you know animals have so it's
my own very own creation but it is
related to a character and you know who
it is you guys exactly know who recon
can hold two swords no I think I know
what it is okay
I'm gonna call them a fork overdrive
from Joe Joe's well yes I doubt he's
watched Joe Joe's probably not okay it's
exciting someone's knocking recons door
drivers so basically and no you go ahead
I just want to say cuz I thought you
were not answer the door so I was gonna
say Jonathan Essex said that he would
want Wolverines healing ability as a
quirk and that would be crazy Wolverine
has a great like he's not he's not a
character that's you know has a super
amazing offensive power naturally he
gets you know the claws and stuff later
but his
his healing ability is definitely
extremely useful so as I was saying my
quirk would be called overdrive and what
this court can do is basically give me
like invincibility frames so I've become
a God for like a few seconds and
basically just charge him like I don't
give a [ __ ] at all and just completely
demolish everything in my way almost
like you're to when that happens like
when he rages so and I'll have like rose
a aura just like Goku black rose' and
just super God for like a few seconds
that would be the limitation of it so
that'll be awesome I think that you
should have a smartphone given to you by
God I feel like that that's kind of like
one for all you have like super strength
and agility and stuff like that
but you know you can't limited energy
you can have negative repercussions you
have to master it and all that kind of
stuff so it's like very powerful quirk
but there's limitations you can you know
it's not unlimited and you have to
actually work hard to master it so
that's an interesting one um the cab
gamers said that he would have a quick
to get a hundred percent on all my exams
with no effort interesting because of
allegedly some people have photographic
memory where they can like you know
while they study they can just like
memorize everything so easily after they
look at it once they don't have to look
at it again so that definitely sounds
like a superpower and so I don't see why
there couldn't be a quirk where you have
like such a photographic memory that
once you study for tests you read
something once over you always get a
hundred percent so I think that's a
doable quirk um you know the many-worlds
parent many worlds theory many worlds
paradox multiverse theory well similar
yeah I guess a quirk where someone can
change which direction they went after a
decision they've made
but kind of like a steins gate stuff
like yeah string fairy more like a raced
huh like you see something you made a
choice and goes back like five minutes
not really go back just transfer it to
the next one so that you choose the
other like line everything something
like that like how long Okabe like
swapped from like one line to it like
another world line and like it's a
different type of reality it so it's
like what's the alternate outcome that
you chose that's pretty cool so that is
done an ability do you want to have lost
who says I don't think I have one thank
you yeah I think it'd be really cool to
be able to control illusions to an
extent like maybe have a prerequisite
like you have to touch them a lot of
five fingers kind of like a what's her
name the girls has to do that and I know
the villain that disintegrates things
also has to do that yes you do raka in
the gravity zero gravity yeah
prerequisite like maybe have something
like that but then you can control one
of their senses like maybe a sense of
time to where they think that you're a
lot faster than you are that way it'd be
pretty overpowered in one-on-one
situations but then if you used it
around a lot of people it it only works
if they don't know what your quirk is
yeah you make them think you have a
different quirk
sorry row yeah so they figure out what
your quirk is then it ruins all things
so if there's other people around and
yes - it changes it changes the
perception of the quirk of someone else
if other time or something else we have
something like that in code geass with
Rolo and his Geass where he stops the
perception of time though I don't think
- overpowered maybe just slow it down to
where it seems like I'm going really
fast or something pull a cutie to you
and there's also think that you have
super speed you make them think that you
can disappeared fairy tale no yo recon
you're the fairy tale-like
yes that was a fairytale guy that fought
the ice dudes
know what say it again the guy that made
everything else slow down so they
thought he was really fast
take out the big nose I'm not I'm not
familiar to is that a thing that is a
thing I know as that as well as that
point is the point is that this is a
recurring theme yeah and I also think
that when you get to the manga there is
a villain called Chronos stasis who I
believe has a similar power we don't
know it's like the thing with my hero
academia is with a lot of quirks we
don't even know their names we don't
know exactly how they work what their
limitations are we only know a little
bit about them mm-hmm awesome hints
right which is interesting to Cano keeps
you guessing but I think that this one
villain seems to have that kind of
ability where he seems too slow and
either time slowed down time or
someone's perception of time
because his the name itself is a hint I
think and he's also known for being able
to have extreme stealth so he's able to
you know sneak up on people very easily
as if I don't like he's stopping time
kind of deal so I think that we might
actually have something like that in my
garage Athena and what else was I gonna
say watch all the anime on your plan to
watch list no it's because everybody
knows me as a harem King so there's
something as a harem King that I would
love to have as a clerk a natural horror
I'm like no no it would be cold dress
break you guys know you guys know where
that is from everybody should know wear
dress break us from know in highschool
DxD not everyone's a huge fan of the
goddamn enemy ever since I first watched
it and I was introduced to dress break
for the first time I was like holy [ __ ]
I want to make girls clothes blow up
like this guy I just touched them once
snap my finger
yes I probably never make you here okay
definitely not sexual harassment court
their harassment what I like girls fall
for you have a thing like Eureka for no
apparent reason that's your quick one
rain yeah like let's say you give off
like a center burkas you give off a
scent that has pheromones that makes
girls attracted to you I think that's a
realistic quirk you have because animals
have such sense that they give out like
so I think that I could potentially
happen in my ear academia I think and
definitely all of us would i'm sure
enjoy having such a quirk although he's
like but the sheep that she loved me for
me or for my quirk and then it's like
that whole existentialist issue and it
depends on the person i mean if it was
mean attack he'd be fine yeah he be cool
has that that's the most guy I love them
feel like my favorite game what if you I
know you that in my video sure and you
got a ton of likes well the only your
Aldo symptom was audio jack girl who
likes her I like audio jack girl
visibility girl
if Eraserhead
invisibility girl what would happen his
quirk doesn't work on people have a
mutation like works to where they what I
don't think you're quickest mutation
like can't be undone like they're just
like that naturally yeah but I think I
wrong is emitter clay but I'm gonna
check this yeah I think it's light it's
bending light that's what her cookies so
if like light were to stop being bent
like what it were like we're to stop
when you see it eventually yes yeah yeah
or maybe he could never look at her
she's invisible and therefore his court
can't work I was also thinking that all
right that's interesting yeah because he
can't look at her
mm-hmm directly you have to make eye
contact the light right she's bending
the light yeah do they have to make eye
contact is that a thing we just need to
look at the person no that's not a thing
you know her her quirk type is
classified as mutant on the wiki at
least so again I don't know 100% know
like some of the wiki information is not
correct because it's just like assuming
stuff that we don't actually know for
sure but if it's mutant than yaki he
should not be able to affect it but then
some people say that he has before been
able to influence a mutant quirt so yeah
I don't know it's interesting something
about the gaming flood kids said if he
would want the quirk to cut his thumb
and become the armored Titan crossovers
all over the place I've got one I've got
one it'll be a fun one though it's not
like you know to be Opie or you know not
even one that you'd essentially use for
combat but you could use it to like
quell combat and that would be the baby
Jesus cook baby Jesus how it works is
once once I activate it
then people would see me as like their
Idol and then that would essentially
make them you know want to follow what I
say so that's that's how my work would
work so it's different for each
individual so I'm I am I like stop for
some bad guy and then he might be you
know you're the [ __ ] that's it come on
guys we got where this guy you know you
might start you know bring me money and
all kinds of things yeah I mean I might
use it like on a cow and a girl might
then be attracted to me thinking that
like I'm a favor I do or something like
that yeah I mean so that'd be mine
maybe Jesus I don't know II wanna be
worshipped like a god sorry go ahead
it sounds like it sounds like Seoul
wants to be a Japanese in a Japanese
girl band no no it's just the fun in it
like I guess life it was in a series
fun like to view it and see it because
it's different depending on who I use it
on and depending on like what that
person sees as you know the higher yeah
I get what you mean so it's like they
predict their own greatest so yeah yes I
mean if if I use them on a recon he'd
probably see Torito if I use that on you
you'd probably see coming if I use that
on pretty Exhibit C Luffy or IPO de Geus
oh yeah oh yeah [ __ ] God Jesus I
would take a power from Joe Joe's
because every stand is an original power
with almost um I'll pick use case now
you know break what but it's not really
know if you're taking it from dojos it's
not original is it then I'm gonna be
original though not original itself I
mean you don't see it in 20 places in
anime it just exists once whenever he
breaks he can reassemble but if you
watch Joe Joe's it's really cool that's
the one yeah overhaul has he's a newer
villain in the manga and he has the
ability to destroy something and then
put it back together as well jojo's so
it's kind of like shigaraki well then
he's able to also put it back together
if you want so that's interesting I mean
if there's a parasite in someone's body
josuke can take a glass of water and
just you know stab it through that
person and it'll shatter and then you
can reassemble it with the parasite in
the glass now thank you doesn't like
episode 1 yeah over Hulk and whatever he
reassembles whatever body part if he
does it on butter card add body part has
no more illnesses so it's similar it
might be inspired by that okay well that
was like a reference yeah it might be a
juror I don't know but just some guy
with a must
said that he would want a core called
omnipresence in YouTube I don't even
know what that means it's not like
anyone watch that YouTube video just
suddenly has to watch your video it's
like all the trending videos like the
top 30 Chinamen is just like one video
of you presence and YouTube is cause
like I feel like I feel like that's a
quirk and I would get on board with
myself I think that sounds like what's
called his Jesus quirk if everyone
watches him they think they're like his
god or like now he's gone like whoever
they think highly of and everyone's
gonna subscribe you're gonna go viral
just post stood they click on it
something like that exactly I think the
most biggest court that everyone would
want is rewind which is to go back in
time let's say to probably pick
something where if you failed your exam
you want to go back in time to try and
pass it or if you did something horrible
in your life you would want to go back
in time then fix this I think that's one
of the most important quirks that you
would want to have within your lifetime
as anyone mentions nothing similar to
that before sound familiar
watch on the chat I've mentioned time
travel not stock who mentioned the the
quirk they erased power right from a
razor but the thing is I don't know if
we should count stuff like that because
it's all old P like rewinding time man I
feel like might be just going too far
like I see you know you know maybe
slowing down time for a certain amount
you know limited amount uh sounds like
something doable but like being able to
go back in time it's like if you look at
Dragon Ball super you look at with this
with power to you know turn back time
for a certain certain number of minutes
like that that can just change
everything know what I mean it's not
going back in time like years and years
back like for a certain amount like you
can probably go up math you can go back
maximum one week you can go back well I
was thinking like you more similar to
the world of broken in here academia
like a quirk that could go back in time
20 seconds today I'll give you like 5
seconds whatever something like that a
little bit too low no for an immediate
mistake if you immediately want to
change it yeah like say you're fighting
someone you get smashed
you go back 3sat
and you dodge it like yeah I think that
would be like a more realistic work than
you know going back by it for a long
period cause then like even that changes
everything Nolan can do anything to you
because you'll be able to follow easy
row yeah you'll be able to exactly
everything and it's like there is a
quirk called foresight in my hair
between me again introducing the manga
but it's limited it only works on one
person for a certain amount of time like
you see what that person is going to go
through for a certain amount of time
kind of thing but yeah like it is along
the same lines of what my hair premium
goes into but we got to try to make it
not too ope just because it would be
like but the cat gamer says he wants a
quirk where he gets to meet anime up or
in real life while eating a potato
that's the dream it's like I say you
have potatoes guys my boy mega anime
opening says mind manipulation and we do
have a guy in my hair Crimea who has
that quark love his name and so yeah
that's right she's a shin so he has the
ability to basically manipulate
someone's mind and control their actions
however Dec who is able to break through
his quark which was coming with the
power of plot armor yes yes but the
mysteries are one for all boy and it
reminds me of Lelouch is Geass again
back to Co Geass because a lot of Geass
power seemed to be relatable to works
where Lelouch can you know control a
certain one person for a certain amount
of period shin so is also able to do
that to one person control their actions
for a certain period you can also do
that if you guys were Charlotte you
could also do that what ooh
the main character you from Charlotte he
has come he takes over their body well
yeah and he controls her action as well
well while his mind is in their body and
his body's unconscious on the floor
isn't that like you know from Naruto or
I think
yes it is ripoff of Ino from there
something everything has been done
before even Jordans are out the anime
dudes what's what's to call it
completely sound like aizen's from from
just doing that the entire time you're
describing like that's literally Ivan's
power like you don't want to let anyone
know what like what your power is but
you can use the illusion to like make
them think it's anything else
there's so opie oh it's also again you
do any genjutsu yeah that's true I like
the concept of shrimp toast power and
like the lucious power oh sorry I
interrupted the ability to control I
think it's very cool very useful
potentially however the problem with
that is again is that Shinto squad was
able to be broken by one for all not
kind of ruin it for me because it's like
oh hi to everyone well II question for
it to be an effective work right into
those powers difference because his
needs a trigger he needs the other guy
to answer one of his questions in order
for them to be under his control then he
can control one guy at a time and him
breaking out with one for all is over
its plot armor it's not the power of his
quirk it's just protagonist power where
Lelouch whoever he looks at he can
control and it's not for a limited
amount of time and he could do it to as
many people as he wants at the same time
he just needs to look at them and Code
Geass they're in massive robots so it's
a little more difficult to do that but
yeah but you're looking in Tokyo says
you can only do it to one person one so
you'll never get one with how many
people do you need to do it to more than
once like if he's up on important people
that you might you might want to control
more like the king or something but yeah
if he's up against sustain like the Deku
was in my hero academia yeah he looks at
staying for two seconds and he says you
are now a teddy bear and that's it
finished you don't need to worry about
that anymore no it's true what I'm
saying if it's someone that he won't
need to keep around they're not just
like you don't get rid of then in that
case it is a bit of a limitation but I
get what you mean that it's very much a
no P power that's for sure
um likely Valentine said he would like
the ability
quark to telepathically communicate with
anyone no matter how far such as a
mapper or Donald Trump so that's it yeah
two good choices yeah you wanna why
would you want to talk to Donald Trump
hey man just annoying
it's like he's sitting in his by his
desk and all of a sudden coming into his
head are anime pictures and whatever
it's like he was gonna make it again we
do have a telepathic quirk that can
communicate modeled uh one of the what
are the names the cat hero group the
Pussycats one of them is it is it
pixie Bob and one of them has the
ability to communicate with people
telepathically she can communicate with
them within a certain range but they
can't answer back they can just hear
what you say so it's kind of like a
one-way intercom that you can have but
it's limited in terms of range so you
can just like anywhere in the world but
yeah that is so again there they do have
something like that in my hero academia
did anybody here on the panel still not
say a quirk other than me
I want to retry since - ooh but so much
depends how you use it you could use it
in earlier into nowhere what if somebody
had a kind of like the professor that he
can cancel quirks or somebody could just
slightly either boost them up a little
bit or power eraser head can cancel
little quirks you can either bust
somebody else's quirk or you can debuff
somebody else or if you feel like a
sidekick type power whereas you you're
kind of useless but okay oh yeah not to
cancel quirks I said similar to that but
like you're boosting up other people's
work so I use it on Baca go these
explosions are a little bit more
powerful than they would be so Kylie a
cleric like you
buf people and I can piece the power or
debuff like give them like a little
produce reduction you would have to
fight in a team and be like a support
sub damn guy you have to be like a
psychic-type character my sidekick I
would say you want a court that makes
you the main person was always the front
line I know everybody works I just
figured I'd try try something else
you could think of work that are not
necessarily oh people that are unique or
original that's I'm totally okay with it
because yeah not everyone is gonna have
a great quirk and I think it's
interesting when characters like stain
who don't necessarily have a great work
and still make it work because of their
own personal sort of dedication and
expertise right about a quirk where you
can move protons and neutrons and make
like air solid or water and get rid of
the hydrogen I don't know something like
that I just like like 200 feet that's
really okay good until someone was like
we make it look yep they're like made me
touch that part or touch that like area
type of thing so it's a little bit less
opie so but you could technically like
like make people's blood clot yeah it's
like game over like your uh your blood
bender from Avatar
yeah waterbending [ __ ] was Oh foxy
those foxy n would like some of the
quick to have the creativity to think of
good quirks I think we would all like
that quirk right about now but you know
what can you do I did a Mac I want to
hear yours there is a quirk in my hero
academia called hydro Kinesis which is
you we can be used to manipulate water
and move it around and it's used by the
rescue hero he uses it to kind of like
put off fires and stuff like that so
that isn't kind of like a waterbending
Tucker cloud the question is can he do
it to other liquids as well like blood
or is it just strictly h2o right like
that's an interesting question to think
about personally personally I think that
some of the quirks that I find the
coolest in miner
include transparency so invisible
invisible girls work but I'm wondering
if she can turn an offer out she never
did probably another I think it's
classified communication
yeah like it's never been it's never
been Connor she's not even shown without
the quark she has this she has the
ability to manipulate light to career
like a solar flare type of effect so the
question is you know can she because I
would I would think that me having the
power to be invisible would be very cool
if you can turn it off and on if you
can't turn it off then it would be not
cool at all right so I'm kind of kind of
I guess on the fence about that because
yeah if you could turn it off and we'll
that'll be an amazing quirk you could
like learn so much useful information be
a spy an assassin you know whatever you
want to do and yeah I've got one it's
called Kirito a quirk that makes Yuuki
Rito damn so you're not real we did swag
that one who dance anyone I want a claw
bility to fall into a coma and have
virtual girls fall in love with you yeah
I just I just want to activate it I just
like my real body just falls down I
collapse and then I wake back up and
look at myself and I'm the real deal I'm
Kirikou okay we're gonna ignore that
take it into your bodies what about like
being able to walk through walls and
stuff I mean put your hand through
someone's head and then solidify it you
know something like that that'd be
pretty cool no no no don't be good for
you either how well the environment well
one of my favorite ones kind of has
something to do with that like the top
hero in the academy I don't really want
to get too much in spoiling the manga
his power seems like it's pretty useless
at first but he like works really hard
to get a grip on it and it's kind of
like that Nux where he goes through the
floor but he ends up being the top hero
at the academy because he kinda
how to utilize this quirk and get it
down more so people deal with theirs
yeah his work essentially lets them move
through objects like walls and stuff so
yeah like I think that would definitely
be a useful work in the real world like
you could be a criminal and just got out
of jail baby no not at any time right so
though that would be quite interesting
wait does everyone have the power to fly
I don't think so
[Music]
I think someone deftly has wings like
someone's yeah yeah no songs got wings
that's for sure so I mean there's a crow
guy or the raven or whatever he is took
a young oh yeah you can fly I think
that's the dragon form dollars are so
you know going back and going basically
flying [ __ ] oh yeah back up in flame
what about a court to control whether
number one they'll be sweet the court I
don't whether kind of x-men right yeah
like if it's raining then you don't like
it you just change it straight away to
like sunny and nice or I don't know
whatever whatever condition you just yes
dork
from x-men tech work would be amazingly
useful yeah and and powerful because you
can use it as a weapon to like you
create a massive thunderstorm you can
create a hurricane if you want or
whatever you want hurricane tornado
they'll be super useful super useful for
sure I would love to be able to teleport
or even like instant transmission like
Goku but I I hate trying to like going
places and they like confrontation I
mean to make it like a little bit like
not through Opie because I could just
like teleport everywhere and you can't
catch me like it's like behind you I'm a
guy have to concentrate really hard to
teleport so like if I got 20 seconds
like period where I have to be like on
topic or people who could attack me and
be free
corner you can only teleport one limb at
a time teleportation
put my love up it's cool gobbles the
ability to create and control crystals
and rocks so being able to create like a
giant armor of crystal and or rocks
that'll be a problem that's like kind of
like earthbending right kind of like
interesting like that Tom Naboo Isha
says quirk to absorb and discharge
elements like fire lightning water so so
rather than being able to create them on
your own you need to have a source for
them but then when you if you have it
like a fire burning or something you can
actually absorb it and create you turn
into a web but I think that's they'll
get interesting work because it is a
limitation right you can't create a look
you know a lightning with all that
they're being lightning to absorb but it
could be very powerful in the right
circumstances carry around the lighter
and a stun gun I'd probably have a
necromancer one yeah yeah like you can
manipulate dead bodies yeah dead bodies
but they like zombies yeah yeah yeah
yeah actually yeah yeah yeah essentially
yeah just completely under your control
so they have their own original powers
or whatever they're just you know
corpses yeah if they add yeah if they
work yeah if they were thingies if they
had quirks then they're a good work how
about this it's called a spoonful the
ability to transform yourself into a
trap
best work ever okay so an
interdimensional box that you could put
whatever you want in that box and
basically wherever you are you just pull
out whatever you put there wherever you
are like basically storage yeah
storage oh that's pretty lame but if I
walk into a fight and I you know I need
my minigun I'll have it
okay um I like like the transportation
thing like warpgate Kudo Gettys warpgate
I think is a very would be a super
useful quirk in real life yeah it's like
imagine living in Toronto like Briggs
does but not having to be in traffic for
eight hours when you're gonna work that
would be [ __ ] awesome if you would
have said kuru Gibby's quark if he
wouldn't have existed in the anime I
would have said a topi I suppose but
then that is a quirk also teleportation
that appears all that you mentioned Goku
right Goku as a rotation and he's ink
Emporium Goku is able to teleport faster
than the freakin gods in that world
yeah like hot like that's that's all I'm
saying there he doesn't like to turn his
body into like particles for that second
tour like he can move super fast or
something like that yeah but like the
point is not even like beutel's can do
that yeah but he has to like travel you
know at a slower pace then Goku I wonder
what I'd leave this don't learn the
ability they they definitely can yeah
yeah I wonder too I guess God still like
plenty or dread who knows we don't we
don't we don't you know we don't we're
above this we don't need this [ __ ] I
accidentally destroyed them ago here you
go how about a court to control like
plants you butter has the quirk to
control vines like her hair is made of
vines and she can control them yes
like imagine it you're fighting someone
on grass and like make the grass grow
super tall and they can't even see you
and then like there you're there near a
tree you extend the branch I grow longer
like you hope like stab them with it you
know how you every look work no matter
how lame it sounds has potential if it's
used properly enough for sure enough and
in the right circumstances right by the
way say if says Ana map or Gigi keep it
up okay I will I don't know that's
referring to but I will definitely keep
it up the khari says will there be a
crook to copy other quirks we already
have a quirk that copies other quirks
with a class one B student what's his
name again
you know the blonde guy can't help you
ya know you got in the back of the head
as the blonde guy yeah he has the
ability to copy a quirk he comes into
contact with for a certain period of
time for like a few minutes
I believe that happened in the Sports
Festival arc if I remember correctly yes
yeah I have a quirk that everyone even
recon would appreciate the ability just
summon a fictional character into real
life I think that's what was talking
about yeah but that would be Sol P like
like no limitations of course like in
recreate errs they all somehow managed
to be in the same power level somehow
okay thank you so yeah like one one
other thing that was mentioned by blood
he says a quirk that could change the
emotions of people and that's
interesting come again situ in Konya
says the ability the Herbie asset to
have people love her kind of like it's
not just like girls being into you cuz
of like hormones it's like an actual you
start feeling love for this person
because of this power so yeah that would
be I think that that's the best idea any
of us came up with so far
you just point to the guy and he starts
crying or whatever you know what a quirk
to turn people into babies well Joe
Joe's has it already which you should
totally watch yeah I just started
watching judges well guess what guess
what bro
Mortal Kombat had it back in the 90s so
what would happen when do you think Joe
Joe's was written let's say like
literally anything you names probably a
jojo's reference that shows everything
it feels like yeah no it is it is a
classic show that I need to watch
because Knox won't leaving me alone I
sometimes at 4:00 a.m. he calls me like
hey bro
Hey
episode 6 of starters Crusaders yo Joe
Joe Joe Joe
hey anime oh he might be telling you to
watch a share with a lot of a lot of
episodes but I think you just need to
watch Coen no katachi 2 hours bro 2
hours oh I actually saw that this week I
think goes in and I should watch it
together and then we could kind of like
both discuss we always like discussing
stuff like that wait Sol brought us the
information they thought Monomoy is the
guy who can copy quirks in my opinion
and man Delaney is the member of the
Pussycats who can use the telepath power
thank you Sol for doing that research um
what a quirk that I think would be very
cool in the modern world especially is
you know how audio jack and mic jack
into things like a work that can not
only create you know sound or something
like that but actually like hack and
control electronics so that like you can
somehow like control computers or you
know make computers not function or
something like something like that in a
modern city that is completely run by
like electronics and computers like you
could be extremely powerful break into
like impregnable places gets you know
get a bunch of secrets shut down an
entire city like that would be I think
an interesting that's from the video
game called watchdogs if you don't know
it it's the main character that has a
phone that can basically hack any
electronics yeah I don't I don't need
anybody I think that would be a definite
deadly quirk in the modern world yeah
yeah
in any hypnosis like type quirk like
Shen so squirt could work like
especially if you could do like I said
closest work that would work through
electronics like you're looking at
someone just for a camera and they can
use a quirk on you like that would be
crazy like you know they just like hack
into the you know the TV broadcasting
system and like use their quirk or like
a bunch of you at the same time like
that would be nuts what about a quirk
like Bethel uses from re0 invisible
hands or something like that or the
actual attack is invisible it can take
over people that's that's his that's his
power yeah but not that part of his
power so like just like a weapon that's
invisible that's pretty cool or like you
could turn your weapons and visible like
saber like oh I think it's a support
fighter and let's say I'm on Totoro Keys
team and he shoots fire and ice but they
are invisible so the opponents cannot
see where it's coming from or what it is
turn something else invisible for a
short time oh yeah that would be very
useful if you know you're gonna sword if
you can't see where it is deadly all
right eight-zero exactly yeah and the
other thing is I think I'm really
interesting quirk that also is in the
actual world of marking it is all for
one or the ability to take other
people's quirks from them now I won't
get into it too much because it's the
manga but that would be like dogging
insane quirk in that world like that's
like well it exists yeah exactly
you ever watch it use the actual the
live TV show no I don't know about it
but I haven't so one had that power -
yeah and that's that would be like again
in a world where there's a whole bunch
of quirks that is an insanely powerful
core potentially if you can use it right
but one thing I want to ask you guys now
is what about in a world where there
wasn't there was no other quirks and you
could be the only one with a quirk what
would be one that you would want so not
necessarily want you to from Naruto hold
on let me let me finish not so not
necessarily a quirk that you need to
fight other people with quirks
none that not EXO not accorded copies
other quirks takes other quirks but
assuming that you're the only one with a
core do you know of what type of work
would you want to have so it can't be
the shadow Kalonji
or you could pick your own Oh then not
the quirk canceller not that can it be
can I tell you why I would want
so aside from the obvious clones and
stuff they also have the opie power that
you also learn whatever they learn and
remember whatever they see so I could
send one to school and I can send one to
I don't know and the real one will be
working out all day obviously right and
then all the other ones will be
gathering knowledge and information and
doing everything I need and then they'll
just poof and I'll have all that
that's pretty unreal like even like you
get if you're watching anime all day and
chilling and like mouthing and then
they'll be out like I'm not the workout
what like transfer but like I love you
like writing your tests making your
YouTube videos yeah random crap to
impress anime ik district I do that all
the time
fight each other they're like I don't
want to be the one doing the test in
school like no I don't want to be that
one they start which one's the real one
yeah I know yeah and again my hero
academia they have a villain called
twice who is able to create clones but
then he actually start fighting over who
was the real clone and it was the clone
who's the real original and who is the
clone so yeah it's an interesting thing
where it's like you've grade the clothes
but then they start having a mind of
their own
oh [ __ ] I'm still the good name twice
yeah gorgeous
vormax once a quirk to turn people into
furries so we know what he's into
and what he wants other people it's
illegal if I had to choose one like that
no one else knew about like I'm the only
one that knows about Mike work if you
like I convinced like anyone of anything
but I stacked evade Mike work and like
you're gonna agree with me and do what I
want to have a thing the power of
charisma yeah the power of communi the
only quirk I would want like just like
Anna Mac said where you're the old one
who has acquired I wouldn't want a quirk
that I can choose any girl I want I just
choose her and then she falls in love
with me straight away we got a casual on
recon what it's creative but then recon
does does she really love you for you or
for for that because she's being - hey
err no I am it's yeah it's manipulative
because I'm harem King I can do what so
you don't know Larry if it's like all of
a facade like facade what is that like a
soul of faith it's all illusion oh yeah
I'm feeling a [ __ ]
I got it better I don't worry and just
go for that x-ray vision you'll be set
x-ray vision yeah that's the thing
that's the thing that Superman has so
why not a quirk like that yeah seeing
through walls
seeing through people's I don't even
want x-ray vision now the problem is
with x-ray vision if you turn it on
where does it go until I mean Superman
can't see through lead
but why like you can see you can't see
through clothes you'd be looking at
someone you'd be seeing a skeleton so
what if you could be like control the
intensity of it it's like a little like
leaver on the side of your head
no but x-ray works so it's not like a
see-through anything is actually extra
next why you got to be such a killjoy
yeah they're ruin it all the ability to
see through fabric that's a power there
we go okay or whatever you wants like
you just like I can't increase the
intensity or decrease like for like the
layers type of thing hunter Souls by the
way says he wants the B think the best
work would be plot armor armor core all
the ability to be the protagonist the
problem is what it's like a side plot or
like a plot where like you die the
ability to be a shounen protagonist
exactly there you know that's the dream
I still think that I should have lost in
that tournament yeah he did earlier I
liked it Knox's did well you guys are
bringing amazing proves from shows of
stuff that happened do you know what you
know what I want I think I know what
souls quark would be Melissa the ability
to make anyone read any manga he wishes
ha ha ha that would yeah I was gonna say
that earlier like for one one of my
quotes all
- just make make recon appreciate anime
that was before 2008 but great court for
recon would be to instill the love for
crap edgy harem anime into anyone else
everyone yeah no that would be a great
squad actually soul Marcus quirk making
people read quality manga versus recons
quark making people love crap be harm HP
anime and it's like who will win who
will be able to take over the world
there's a right wants you to watch the
edges is what I need be still wins
quickly
nick says he wants quark Captain America
I don't get it quark america [ __ ] yeah
so what i didn't hear your cork what did
you say the ability to have me write a
manga what manga would you the ability
you would have the ability to instill
love and passion for a cheater I'm
cracked into anyone
wait so you would stop me from loving my
my stuff no you would have the power to
do it to everyone else
Oh that'll be cool Morgan says just like
that recon became an antagonist market
says a quirk called safe point where
every your every birthday the game saves
over so you can reload at any time
that's kind of like every zero yeah it's
kind of like Undertown work from Reiser
XIV has to die for it to reload Luna
says quark ruled the world yes moon
about how how to rule the world that's
the quark ruling the world is just what
happened as a result law says he wants
levi's magic there's a quirk from a
fairy town what woman you make let me
not leave my leve oh yeah yeah yeah you
made the word we
no Justin Law just said one that's kind
of terrifying
he said the change all traps to female
you can change people's and gender kind
of like a Bond Cove from one piece or
something how about a court to turn your
body into liquid whenever you want and
then back you have not power week on
just sounds so wrong no what do you mean
there's some song you would really wish
you'd be the water coming out of you
like girls like showers oh yeah that's a
good idea
[Music]
don't worry I just come out of the look
and I just come out of the you know the
drained air at whatever yeah and that's
the water logia we're all dead
hey here behind transform bike into you
when I say surprise [ __ ] I'm
here
surprise [ __ ] why don't you just
recon why don't you just have the quirk
called being a normal nice confident
human being and then girls will actually
want to spend time with you anyways you
don't have to you know do all these like
sneaky ways of getting with chicks you
can just be like chicks want to be with
you anyways gotta bring some
entertainment for people that's wrong
here I'm here to make people entertained
it's true he has been doing that very
entertaining young to think of stupid
quirks that would hopefully entertain
people that's that's what I'm doing you
be doing a great job keep it up yeah I
feel like also um II does quark engine
is pretty useful to like just being
really really fast I mean I think that's
cool
wonder how much worn shoes he drinks
crank that word a lot that's cool - at
least he doesn't have to like drink
gasoline yeah that would suck that would
have After Effects of lead you know he
has to dream like a nice orange juice
drink not know to not like it too bad
for you or anything so just Frankie
what's called from one piece like drink
Cola be like make yourself a style build
the staircase into midair - exactly the
ultimate ship right of the ultimate uh
architect oh and he has massive laser
guns and a Mac tis true I love you thank
you
there's a student in class 1b that has a
quirk that his name is manga his face is
just like a thought bubble and his quirk
is comic but no one knows what it does
but golden was I bought something what
if it is to make comics come to life
well that's like bringing fictional
characters to life yeah like that will
be they'll be crazy old peak work you
can bring your wife with a life at
Amerikan Oh to life yeah a Rika would
that be your choice would there be your
number one choice for Rika no bring work
if I want to quark like that I can just
buy loads of body pillows and just bring
them all too late yeah then they'll beat
the crap out of you and run away with
the diamond boy I thought I could be
pretty cool too big dream no characters
to life I can't bring like Lelouch to
life well you can't control them though
I'd be like part of the thing I get to
have like control over them you have to
pick one of those [ __ ] the downside
would be like you have to be able to
draw the character like however you draw
them that's what they look like oh so
you're a hentai artist so you can bring
your pictures for life
yeah yeah yeah like first of all if
someone who could actually other quark
and you could keep using it it would
make a crapload of money yeah you could
make a crapload money you could be the
guy it's like hey listen I will you
design you tell me what you want I'll
draw it I'll bring it to life and you
and you give me insane amounts of money
like I'll be crazy however maybe that
that quark would be more realistic if
let's say you could only life ever or
something so you have to choose like a
specific character I feel like if
anybody got that quark it'd be somebody
like me that can't draw worth a lick
like that samurai have a one-piece where
the drawings just look terrible yeah
that's that's funny that would be like
that would be like a comedic thing where
it's like someone who only draws like
stick figures is the guy who has that
quirk well he brings people to lie but
it's just like a bunch of stick figures
are like falling over themselves because
their legs are too short
yeah the champ said a quirk that affects
your strength and speed is Hana based on
their emotions so like if you're angry
you're stronger but obviously could
potentially have some drawbacks as well
because like you can't necessarily
control your emotions so it's like that
will be funny - it's like you carry my
god when you're nervous let's say when
you're nervous you start moving really
fast so then you were on the girl you
just are and you can call the quark
adrenaline the ability to turn things
into poison or like so I got like poison
people easily oh you you're talking
about from hitman reborn my girl oh yeah
I don't even remember her and I've
watched him ever learned Hayatou sister
yeah Jonathan Essex set a quirk that
puts people into comas I think that's
the four kids version of Death Note
right knocks that's right go look up the
official trailer it's on YouTube oh my
god no actual train
it's a no-knock staggered yeah by the
way guys everyone's everyone here their
channel limps that has a channel or in
the description if you want to check
them on of course don't forget to leave
a like on this video if you enjoy rank
up they want to see more of these we do
them every week 5 p.m. Eastern Time
Thursdays so yeah it's always fun time
like this before we get finished I want
to see you know some more suggestions of
existing quirk in my hair at the AMIA
that you would really want to have in
real life like your top number one you
have to pick one that you know right now
anime dude hey what I think work you
ruined the the hype oh you know dude you
don't realize no one listens to the
outros so we just have to go with it no
yeah you have to you have to animate
dude you have to pick one quirk that
exists already so now one you created in
real life what would it be I kind of
like the electric dudes quirk because
you can charge his own phone useful cell
can be done for an echo an hour but I'm
already kind of dumb hood not that big
of a deal yeah yeah that is true ever
dude I accept your answer
Thank You Briggs do you I went down I'll
be down now the girls quark if I could
turn it on it on and off I think that'd
be really applicable I don't know same
here that would probably be my top
choice if you could turn it off but if
you can't totally not even close
I can't think of another one by the way
caster for life says this quark would be
England is my city please let me know
down it in the chat what you guys
thinking when is my city clerk would
actually do because I think that's a it
would make your caller stay pumping you
where you're going anyway
it could be t-shirt the t-shirt will
have a popping collar
lexical mic work is to be the ultimate
meme stir stir people to like come up
with amazing memes like England is my
city you go viral
jojo's leave me alone
yeah that would backfire you become a
Jake Paul bra like no matter how much
hate he's getting I still think like
people would want to be in his shoes
yeah but he's losing perspective man
like he's oh yeah you taking it too far
okay um
anime mouth overhaul he likes me yeah
very very cool quirk and again some
quirks are useful not only for yourself
but for others so like works like
recovery and overhauls work that can
regenerate stuff can be very useful like
for your allies you could like heal your
allies stuff like that or people you
care about so yeah those would be
definitely really useful works
um recon to you one existing quirk that
you have to pick I would choose
Tatiana's quirk oh I would want to have
a shadow and you'd want to look like a
chicken no my own shadow like as nor to
Oh stab your own shadow so you want to
be a stand user no no I just want to
have toffee Atmos quark I think it's
cool
tell the relative Englanders my city
makes you dab 24/7 even when you sleep
you think that's so Jake Paul actually
sleeps like you're someone's like some
I'm sleeping noodling only if he's
getting hate so yeah probably
stabbing all the time yeah I've been on
all the time and there's so many haters
to dab on like you don't know did you
see your tweet got on Aki's video oh yes
I did
yeah that was cool yeah when I was in
that Jake ball zone I was just because
we were making the it's anime bro video
so I was just
no I saw all you tweets and whenever you
are on discord you had something like
Liddy or you know one word more Jake
ball references than an 11 year old girl
let's just say that that's good and yeah
and then Aki asked on her Twitter like
some dares for people to give them to do
while they were playing like a
rock-paper-scissors cocky guru style
game and I said say da da condom haters
and then proceeded to dab in a public
setting and she actually had to do it
but I was stupid I should have said
that's exactly there's because she went
like she went to the camera line but if
I said shout she wouldn't have to do it
and everyone would have heard because
they were like a grocery store so yes
yes I messed up there but it was a
hilarious video definitely check it out
any other any other interesting there
was also adopted them haters quark idea
is my city
how does meme as well I would have a
quirk called nailed it everything I
could do no matter how awkward it comes
out everyone thinks it's the best thing
ever or how about the quirk makes you
think that it's the best thing ever and
everyone else is like what the hell is
in my life all of this a recons life
story - what are you talking about
freaks Samuel Anna's a quirk than
physical physical ionization that like
analyzes people's fighting style and
physical strength and stuff
I feel like that's if Dec who has a
quirk it's that it's the ability to
analyze people and there's no he was
what girl a coach off of
coño basket can do that right mommy yes
recon you haven't watched coconut basket
he's mute
so Animax I guess you didn't watch
coconut mez did oh my brother loves it I
just don't like sports anime that much
so I haven't really gotten into a lot of
sports anime the only one I like this
cage oh you got a watch I dunno equal
bro yeah I know I'd recommend it to me
so much like trying to pick Hajime no
Ippo are high q-- and just the one I'll
watch when I you know when I'm like okay
I'm gonna watch sports I'm is gonna be
our Japan Amelia forest for sure but of
course Rica wouldn't watch it because
it's not from 2010 and up so you mean
2015 I've heard this argument no ippo
I've watched that have you actually yeah
I watched it it was not good respect
respect respect tree count more than a
put the rising sweet it's so sick right
yes really like Lum King says quirk one
punch yeah that would be an old be quick
right I like Nick victory fires quark
when he said fusion quark we confuse two
bodies together for an amount of time
like in full Anita from formal alkaloids
no I'll make Dragonball is like crazy
flowers like it's not even fair like
Dragon Ball is like it's just like a cut
above like other in it because it's so
low P o box
okay for the non quirks I'll probably
Eva have Momo's creation or just
hockey's overhaul yeah we forgot about
soul maka their creation really yeah
Andy thank you all
you don't forgot about you last but not
least right so if I wouldn't look like a
shadowy blob I would take you to duties
for sure yeah the question is can kuroky
return at all that's another thing so he
wears a suit
how does he wear a suit some people
say he can just turn it off and on in
terms of like the density of his body
but he wants to hide his identity so he
keeps it on but he could look like a
normal person
yeah look like a normal person that
would be a great quirk all right so then
I would pick it Alan and me I would
definitely pick all for one awful you
said like it was in the world without
quotes no no yeah I said that uh
previously but then this was just kind
of like if you could pick any existing
quirk which will be again invisible girl
if you could turn it off for sure but if
not for one because what's the best grip
to take over the world it's definitely
all for one create an army of crazy
people would combined insane quick
combos just crush it I'd love to see
that well thank you guys we're gonna
wrap it up now it's been a great ranked
affair really enjoyed talking about
these quirks with you guys
thank you to Knox otaku all day anime
anime recon the anime dude and soul maka
the channels of those people other than
someone who still is on my channel are
in the description they'll make quality
content on the youtubes and Sol will
eventually make a channel one day maybe
maybe maybe when Seoul makes a channel
recon will read manga you never know hey
actually I do since you might you know
recommend manga then yeah I would give
it a go I've been recommending the manga
for the last how many months it's gotta
be it can be a YouTube for my road pull
a pool on who's gonna do what first is
soul gonna started YouTube channel Oris
recon going to start reading manga and
then we just have like just cash money
flowing all that fine that entails that
recon would be able to read more than
just subtitles I've always been aiming
only this this is lovely rivalry love
you guys
but okay we're gonna wrap it up now if
you guys want
like this leave a like if you want to
continue the conversation you can join
the discord server link in the
description always fun time over there
and yeah thanks again everybody good
guests everyone in the chat awesome
comments and until next time see you
space cowboys bang bang